Being behind on your bills can be a very scary place
Starting baby step one is a great goal.If you are behind, right now you need to get current on your bills.
Dont even worry about your beginner emergency fund of
$1000. Pay your bills first. You need to take care of what we call the 4 walls. These are basic things we all need.
food shelter and utilities
Transportation and
Clothing so what do you do first? Eat, buy food for your family?
That's the very [first] thing you do the next thing you do is keep the lights and water on
After paying utilities take care of shelter. that means pay the rent or mortgage.
Then you move on to transportation and once you know [you] can get where you need to go with gas in [the] tank
Then you can take care of your basic clothing needs. don't go all out on brand name fashion
Just buy what you need?
here's a tip don't get behind on your home and be current on your
Mastercard and your student loan if you're going to be behind on something choose to hold off on things [that] don't matter as much
They're called unsecured creditors creditors that don't have any security they don't have a lien on anything
They're not going to take away basic
necessities of your life if you have a place to live
It's warm and the lights are on your stomach is full
And you have clothing to wear and a way to get to work [you] [live] to fight another day
The four Walls are in place and worry
starts to slip away when your lights are about to be cut off but you've paid your mastercard Bill
That's when life starts spinning out of control
You won't win in that situation put the four walls of your home up first then work your way [through] the other stuff
It's all about priorities